LET’S GO DOWN STAIRS TO AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH BRIAN
EVERYONE WANTS MORE DON’T WE.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA PARENTS
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THE SCHOOL
VACCINE MANDATE BY STAGING
MASSIVE WALKOUTS ACROSS THE
STATE A MOTHER OF THREE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHO KEPT HER
DECIDE HOME FROM SCHOOL
YESTERDAY.
THERE’S THEIR BEAUTIFUL PICTURE
LINDSAY JOINS US WITH A MESSAGE
TO STATE LEAD LEADERS GOOD
MORNING LINDSAY.
WHY DID YOU KEEP YOUR KIDS HOME
YESTERDAY?
>> MY KIDS STAYED HOME YESTERDAY
FOR SEVERAL REASONS.
WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE
MOVEMENT TO SEND A STATEMENT TO
OUR GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS THAT
THEY ARE OVERREACHING THEIR
ENCROACHING OUR PARENT RIGHT AND
ENCROACHING ON RIGHTS OF
EDUCATORS AND STAFF WITH THESE
MANDATES.
AINSLEY: I KNOW LIKE IF A BIG
COMPANY OF PEOPLE IF THEY
DEMONSTRATE AND DON’T GO TO WORK
COMPANY LOSES MONEY LIKE
SOUTHWEST HAVE TO CANCEL FLIGHTS
THAT KIND OF THING BUT IN YOUR
AS MUCH AS WHAT’S THE IMPACT
THERE?
WILL THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
LISTEN?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WILL BE
INTERESTING TO FIND OUT THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND DISTRICT WHERE
I’M LOCATED IT IS TAKING QUITE A
BIT FOR THEM TO LISTEN TO
PARENTS.
AND I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW,
MOVEMENTS LIKE ONES THAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY THERE’S A LOT
OF LOGISTICS THAT GO INTO IT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
SUPPORTED THE WALKOUT AND JUST
AS MANY WHO WANTED TO SUPPORT
BUT THEY FEAR RETALIATION OR YOU
KNOW THEY FEEL A SENSE OF
DEDICATION TO THEIR TEACHERS
SO --
YOU KNOW, THEY DIDN’T
PARTICIPATE.
BUT I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
STUDENTS THAT DID NOT SHOW UP
YESTERDAY.
WE HAD SOME STAFF THAT DID NOT
SHOW UP YESTERDAY.
AND I THINK IT’S JUST, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THOSE DISRUPTIONS THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND MAYBE
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
AND UNTIL WE GET A VOICE.
AINSLEY: I KNOW THAT YOU’RE AN
EXPERT IN HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY
YOU’RE A NURSE, YOUR HUSBAND IS
A FIREFIGHTER THESE ARE BOTH
CRITICAL TO YOUR COMMUNITY.
YOU’RE NOT ANTI-VAX RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NO.
I THINK THAT’S PROBABLY AN
IMPORTANT THEY THINK TO
UNDERSTAND AND THAT I THINK
MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT I
KNOW THAT PARTICIPATED YESTERDAY
CONTRARY TO THE PERCEPTION
THAT’S OUT THERE ARE NOT
ANTI-VAX MY KIDS ARE VACCINATED,
AND YOU KNOW WITH SEVERAL
DIFFERENT VACCINES.
AND --
BUT NOT WITH COVID --
>> EVERY PARENT HOPEFULLY.
>> NOT WITH COVID VACCINES NO.
DGES AND WE ACTUALLY MY KIDS AND
I HAD COVID OVER THE SUMMER.
BUT I WAS GOING TO SAY LIKE
EVERY PARENT OUT THERE FOR THE
LAST 18 YEARS I’VE BEEN MAKING
DECISIONS ON MEDICAL DECISIONS,
AND SAFETY DECISIONS FOR MY
CHILDREN.
BASED ON PROS VERSUS CONS RISK
VERSUS BENEFITS, AND I THINK
THAT A LOT OF US PARENTS, YOU
KNOW, THE UNKNOWN WITH THE
VACCINE YOU KNOW WE’RE SEEING
SOME --
PEDIATRIC POPULATIONS THAT ARE
HAVING IMMEDIATE RESPONSES TO
THE VACCINE THAT ARE NOT
FAVORABLE.
BUT WE’RE ALSO THE UNKNOWN FOR
THE FUTURE IS ENOUGH FOR SOME OF
US TO SAY WE’RE NOT KIVEL DOING
THIS AND WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT RIGHT.